er ist jahrzehntelang nicht hinbekommt
schulen mit computern auszurüsten
von dem ist dann auch kein impftermin zu
erwarten oder darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit dem fdp- generalsekretär volker
wissing der mir zugeschaltet ist schönen
guten tag herr wissing warum ist
deutschland so bräsig also wenn man sich
anschaut wie wir uns schwer tun
wirtschaftshilfen auszubezahlen
dann kann man sagen die administrativen
oder die verwaltungsstrukturen in
deutschland passen nicht mehr zu einem
modernen land und sie sind inzwischen
auch ein hindernis geworden und deswegen
ist das etwas was dringend geändert
werden muss und ehrlich gesagt im
internationalen vergleich sieht das im
augenblick nicht wirklich gut aus für
deutschland deswegen wir müssen aufholen
aber wir können das in unserem land
steckt so viel in den menschen steckt so
viel
wir brauchen typen die lust haben auf
zukunft die freude an neuen technologien
haben typen die an neues glauben und an
die chancen die dahinter stecken und
nicht nur besitzstandswahrer die
zurückblicken und die sich über die
glorreiche vergangenheit freuen dabei
ist solche leute wie ugur sahin die
wirklich innovationstreiber auch sind in
unserem land dass sie auch als berater
oder wenn sie denn lust haben auch als
teil einer politischen mannschaft uns
guttun würden ich finde wir sollten da
überhaupt mehr quereinstieg zu lassen in
der politik